hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my non-spoilery Suicide Squad
review I'm going to do a separate video
with Easter eggs later this week so here
we go so some of you seeing this will
probably have a lot of questions about
some of the twists in the movies some of
the characters the way they left things
at the end of the film so I'll try to
answer some of that in his non-spoilery
away as possible at the end of this
video but just to talk about the
characters I will say like far and away
I feel like the best character to come
out of this is Diablo after that Harley
Quinn in Deadshot so naturally like a
lot of the film is built around them and
I feel like that works to its benefit
but there are so many characters in this
that a lot of the criticisms that you've
probably been reading online of the film
are mostly due to that like just trying
to juggle all these characters like I
felt like Jai Courtney was doing some
really fun stuff in the movie but his
character Captain Boomerang was more of
a caricature in the movie than an actual
character with an arc but most of you
knowing that in chanters is in the film
they deal with some really big ideas
that they haven't dealt with in the DC
Universe before this is kind of like the
welcome to magic movie so I'm really
excited about where they take it from
here because one of the things that's
different now is you know because they
have multiple movies than the new DC
movie universe this is connected to
Batman V Superman in multiple ways with
multiple different types of characters
so you know without giving away spoilers
I will say yes you will definitely spot
some really awesome extended DC Universe
stuff happening magic thus far has been
kind of a wild card even with the TV
shows like just the way they deal with
magic usually it's easier to deal with
traditional metahumans and that is kind
of like the blanket term that the movie
uses for anybody that has powers of any
kind no matter how their powers work so
people that can use magic
they're called metahumans people that
are possessed by otherworldly spirits
like enchantress they're called
metahumans the movie even calls Superman
a metahuman and for those of you that
are really big fans of the Richard
Donner Superman films there is a
Superman to deep cut kind of
tongue-in-cheek joke during this big
Amanda Waller scene where she's briefing
all this people in this meeting room so
keep your eyes peeled for that I'll
explain all the easter eggs and stuff
when I post my Easter Egg video later
this week there was a big comic book
storyline that the movie adapted it's a
little hard to rank this just because
there aren't that many movies in the new
to DC universe but I still say you know
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight probably
my favorite DC film so far this
definitely cracks top 5 there are a
couple moments where I feel like you
know performances weren't quite as
OnPoint as they could have been like in
chantry's like when things go over the
top they go really over the top and I
feel like you know Jared Leto's
performance as the Joker is going to be
a big point of interest for people just
because the Joker is such a big
character because he's following Heath
Ledger who is basically acknowledged as
having one of the best cinematic not
just best Joker performances but best
cinematic villain performances in the
last 20 years so no matter how good you
think Jared Leto is it's just really
hard to follow that so he definitely
appreciated the actors performances that
were playing characters that have
already been portrayed on screen like
Harley Quinn there have been a lot of
Harley Quinn's before but margot robbie
does a great job now Batman aficionados
will really appreciate this but Margot
Robbie said that her inspiration for the
character for like the crazy like when
her character goes really crazy was
actually Arlene Sorkin's performance of
you know the original appearance of the
character in the animated series but
because that voice is so over the top
she couldn't really use it for the
really serious Harlequin moments like
there's a whole spectrum of Harley Quinn
in the movie like there's Harley Quinn
being really crazy
there's her being a little more serious
there's her being more earnest so in
order to make the character feel more
real a lot of the regular Harley quit
like when Harley Quinn's at baseline
when she's not being super crazy that
performance was inspired by a lot of the
females in Goodfellas which is basically
like Long Island mob housewife which is
kind of what Harley Quinn would be like
Gotham City would have its own version
of Long Island where she would probably
try to live with the Joker so for those
that are asking about more Harley Quinn
yeah she will definitely pop up more in
the DC movies Margot Robbie's one of the
best things about this movie of course
I'm expecting her and the Joker to pop
up in Justice League somewhere but aside
from the straight Suicide Squad sequels
they've actually talked about doing a
film centered around Harley Quinn I feel
like she would benefit from her own film
she did definitely do it by herself
but any movie that she's in would have
to involve the Joker like I feel like
they just come as a pair
so just to be determined DC has just
said that they're working on a Harley
Quinn movie but they haven't exactly
said what that's going to be I'm just
expecting something close to Gotham City
sirens
those either read the comics but other
characters Amanda Waller probably the
best villain in the movie you know you
probably go into this knowing that
Amanda Waller is way worse than all of
the worst members of the Suicide Squad
and of course Viola Davis is so amazing
she's just like slam dunking each one of
her scenes so let's see who else katana
is a relatively minor character you know
feel like she did some interesting
things in the movie but her character
isn't really fleshed out so I would
expect more fur in the next Suicide
Squad movie Killer Croc is a lot of fun
because he is such a Batman character
there's always the possibility that he
could come back during the Batman solo
film it just depends on which characters
they want to include in that but he was
a lot of fun surprisingly funny too like
a lot of characters get very funny
moments that you wouldn't expect from
them and you definitely feel like the
movies an action comedy you know much
more so than say like Batman V Superman
like they're all badasses in their own
right but in the comics they're largely
sold on their comedy like usually the
action is always secondary to all the
comedy so my only real criticisms
against the film are like their ultimate
goal like the you know their ultimate
victory is more of an emotional victory
like the movies all about them coming
together as a team we're more of a
family with more honor than the people
that we're working for and you know
namely like Amanda Waller in Argus so
the movie did a really great job of
getting that across and like that's the
most important thing but you also have
to have like the villain that you punch
in the face you have to have a clear
understanding of what the villains
trying to do it like what their evil
plan is why it is they're doing what
they're doing in the movie isn't so
clear about that I'll talk a lot more
about what the villains big plan is when
I get to spoilers because it is modeled
after a comic book arc but they change a
lot of things from that comic book arc
especially the way the characters work
so I can't really talk about that
without getting into spoilers but I will
say you know definitely a lot of fun
there will definitely be more Suicide
Squad films particularly with Deadshot
Harley Quinn Killer Croc and hopefully
Diablo like Diablo has an amazing arc in
this but the really fun thing about the
movie is is that it leaves the
characters in a relatively ambiguous way
so that they could totally come back at
any film anytime they want but there's
also room for you to speculate about
their place in the other movies that are
going to be happening in the future
so if you guys have seen the movie let
me know in the comments who's your
favorite character and what do you think
about the way they introduce magic into
the DS
universe is really a much bigger deal
than the movie makes it out to be and I
love the way the characters in the movie
like the normal characters like Amanda
Waller the other government people react
to it like normally if you showed
someone some magic they would poop their
pants they would throw up like they'd go
crazy but because they've already been
through the drama of what happened with
Superman so a lot of the characters
reactions are really funny but like I
said my easter egg video will post later
this week they'll be much more Marvel
and DC stuff happening before then so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
be sure and go see the movie this week
so feel free to leave any questions
about the movie in the comments but
please use a spoiler tag if you're going
to be super specific while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here to learn more about the flash
season 3 and flashpoint and you can
click here for my Justice League trailer
video thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you